Hi and welcome to the Neil Ashton podcast.
In each episode,
we explained some of the fascinating ways that science and engineering
are changing the world around us.
We talk to leading engineers from elite level sports like cycling and Formula One
to some of the world's top academics to understand how fluid dynamics,
machine learning and supercomputing
are bringing in a new era of discovery.
We also hear some of their life stories, their career advice
and lessons they've learned on the way that I hope will be helpful to you too.
So sit back and enjoy this episode.
Hi and welcome back to the Neil Ashton podcast.
So today's guest is Professor Dore
Zamy who is a professor at the University of Michigan and is
also the director of the Michigan
Institute for Computational Discovery and Engineering.
And he has become actually one of the key voices in this area of AI for science coming
from the fluid dynamics background. In fact, actually, we we discussed that
many of the people moving and being pioneers in A
I for science which covers of course science in general,
actually coming from a fluid dynamics uh background and he is probably
to some best um best known for his work actually in turbulence modelling
uh in the sense of the seminal paper that he did turbulence modelling in the age of data
that
back in 2019, although I,
you know, we discussed, he actually started that work 2012, 2014,
which was well before
the current uh hype and, and rise of machine learning and AI
and that paper. And that work really,
um
I would say motivated the whole community to, to really look at machine learning.
And he's progressed from that point
to, to actually broaden out um not only into more general fluid dynamics,
but also covering, you know, the sciences.
Uh and, and really focusing in the role of machine learning and AI.
In fact,
one of the uh Pacific areas that he has really
tried to push in recent years and bring the community together
is around uh foundational models for science.
Uh certainly a hot topic and something of, you know,
potentially huge significance.
So in this episode, we, we mainly focus on these debates around AI for science
and we do limit ourselves um a little bit into
the fluid dynamics and computational fluids um fluid dynamics domain,
but really trying to get a sense of where this field is going.
And here's some of his thoughts
uh starting in the turbulence modelling side.
So where does he see the current progress when
it comes to using machine learning in that side.
And he's, you know, careful to,
to remind everybody that he,
he's not trying to say that this replaces the need for humans.
It's just an additional tool that they can use in the development of these methods.
And then we,
we broaden the discussion a little bit to go
into more surrogate modeling and his thoughts around,
you know, PINNs—physics-informed neural networks,
how he sees their potential to replace
or does he see their potential to replace PDEs
solvers?
Um
And then we really get into a,
a reasonably detailed discussion on foundational models.
What he believes foundational
models are his thoughts on maybe even
how large language models using transformer um
architectures could still be used in many parts of scientific discovery.
But using um
you know, simulation tools as agents within that,
I thought that was a really interesting part of the discussion we had,
I also asked him about the role of academia and industry and start ups in this space.
And we have a discussion around also some of his advice for,
for students and aspiring academics and
some of his opinions on,
on his enjoyment of being in academia and the career path that that he's taken
as we I say this in almost every single episode.
Um Even though this, you know, we spoke for more than an hour,
there were many topics we didn't really get to cover.
And that's why I put some links uh in the chat.
Certainly, if you're watching this on, on YouTube,
uh if you're listening to this uh on Spotify, Apple,
maybe you can go to the YouTube channel to see some of those links
where I,
some of the summer schools that he's organized and symposia,
which had some really fantastic speakers.
And also I think they have the,
some of the slides and talks that he gave where he goes into even more detail into
some of the specifics that perhaps we were ever able to get into in this episode.
So,
um I, yeah, this is uh along the theme of um
as I mentioned, the, the the past episode we did and there's a few more coming
that really focuses on this AI for science and, and he is really a key voice in
this that I hope you'll learn a lot from. So please sit back
and enjoy this episode with Professor Do
Ay,
the MICDE or the Michigan Institute for Computational Discovery and Engineering.
So
it's a institute across the entire um campus.
There are more than 180 faculty members
looking at all kinds of disciplines, you know,
from computational medicine to biology, to uh astrophysics, to climate modeling.
But of course, as a researcher,
my uh applications tend to be
somewhat close to fluids, but not
in the sense of seven or eight years ago.
Um
So my work has maybe moved closer to computational science and AI,
um, rather than fluid specific. But of course, many of my applications tend to be
close to fluids but not exclusively.
Ok. Yeah,
I mean,
that's, it's always nice, isn't it to expand a little bit?
I guess there's a, there's a trade off, isn't there?
Like, there's a lot of transferable knowledge
from, I guess, fluid dynamics outside, which is useful,
um, to bring, do you think that's
important,
particularly in the age of um AI
where methods are coming from different disciplines?
In fact,
since
we are on this
uh few months ago, I kind of
had a consortium of
uh institute directors across various universities. There was
PTOs
Kumars
Soos at Harvard, Ken Wilcox at
Texas, John Luca
Ario at Stanford,
YF Marzuk at MIT.
And what is common to all of these people, fluids applications?
It's kind of weird, right?
You know, they are, the institutes are very broad in scope.
But I think
because of the scale of the problem and
certain peculiarities about fluid dynamics, uh I think some of the
knowledge and methods that we develop here
tend to be
asking questions that are very hard.
And so I think assimilating other information or taking these to other methods,
I think it's a bit of a bridge but of course,
I could be biased.
Um
but it sounds like a good career advice for people.
If you want to become the director of a top institute,
go down the fluid dynamics route.
Because statistically
the other way to think about it is if you never
want to solve the problem that you want to solve,
you want to pick fluids and turbulence in particular.
But you gain so many different skills in that
frustrating process of not being able to solve anything.
I'm being tongue in cheek here. But,
but, but, but seriously, I do think there is something here, right? Because
um you know, if you look at
uh
you know, the development of computational fluid dynamics,
uh it has a very strong connection to numerical methods in general,
right?
And you can and
many other disciplines, you can see like a diffusion of these ideas.
But yes, there is certainly
some of the problems are so hard,
you know, and that is this quote. I don't know who said it.
It said turbulence is the graveyard of all
ideas that are successful in other fields.
But you can also flip that and you can say
many of the methods that we use to probe turbulence and modern it,
you know, can have applications in many other disciplines because
this is in a sense, a
hard and intractable problem.
But
end of the day, I'm still an engineer, right? So
we still can get very useful things out.
Yeah,
I I maybe want to start a little bit on um
and it would be good to
please correct me if I'm wrong. But I think one of the areas that
um
really brought you to the national or international stage
was the pioneering work,
the turbt
modeling paper that you did looking at data driven turbulence modelling.
Uh at least from my side, I suddenly
I found those papers and those review papers
incredibly useful. And I know many other colleagues, it sort of
brought it to the attention to the, to the point I would say arguably now,
so many
people I know at least in the Fluids Domain
have PhD students have projects and many of them are
citing that sort of as an original piece of work.
That sort of kick started. Uh a lot of this off uh turbots
modeling in the age of data was that your,
was that also your sort of first
uh move into machine learning and, and
sort of more data science from your prior background, maybe more as a pure
uh
quote unquote turbulence modeling or, or engineer.
Yeah, I mean, uh yeah, there is, I mean, first of all,
I that paper you referred to is he wrote it in 2018,
that was already six years into the work that I've been doing in the field.
But you're right, that is
the first entry for me into
data science, machine learning type of areas.
Um And I I was never really a turbulence modeler as you or your adviser were. Um But uh
it was certainly AAA good chunk of my thinking back in
15 years ago or so.
Um And, and the entry into the field was a bit interesting.
So I was working on this idea called structure based turbulence modeling.
It's very advanced.
So
think of writing equations for a three dimensional tensor. So 27 equations,
of course, there symmetries and things you can eliminate a few.
And there, even though we were going more and more fundamental into the theory,
by the time you were
developing a,
a
true turbulence model,
there are just so many uncertainties, so many
functions that we had to make up so many coefficients we had to fit.
So we said, yeah, this is probably
a task that
data science can address.
And of course, at that time, big data was
everywhere. This is,
this is the world of,
you know, Walmart saying big data is going to be the next big thing kind of thing.
So yeah, that's how I entered the field. You're right in that sense.
Um Yeah, I
I started this in
this 2012, 2013 time frame
and I think for a few years,
there was literally nobody at least in
turbulence and CFD doing that.
Uh at least,
yeah, for these kind of problems and then, yeah, the field kind of
took off.
Yeah, that's kind of incredible in a way.
Now when you look back, it's hard to split the now to then
because now machine learning AI is literally
everywhere you you can't even watch the television,
listen to anything without being on
where probably in 2012, 2013,
was it even a struggle to get funding with the
funding agencies not even fully appreciating it or was it,
as you say, more under a different banner?
This
big data
um
banner?
No, I must count myself lucky because the very first proposal I wrote when I
came to the University of Michigan,
I think it was called turbulence modeling.
I think it was something to do with big data and turbulence modelling in, in, in the title
and they got funded. It was one of,
I think they had,
I
submitted to
NASA, I think they had about 90 proposals and this
14 and haven't been one of them.
So I was lucky in the sense that
when I started, even before my ideas were fully formed,
I just shot out a proposal and it got funded and I must say
it has not been a struggle at any point to get funding because
uh maybe
I got the timing right or, or whatever I asked the right questions, I don't know.
But uh
being ahead of
the curve in terms of, you know, what needs to be done or what
needs to be looked at,
I think helps.
But that doesn't mean
the problem is anywhere close to being solved as I mentioned earlier.
But yeah, it has been,
yeah, that was my entry point.
And yeah, it's been good to be
um
close to the center of the field and
see what people have been doing.
So maybe for people
who are not as familiar, how would you describe
the state as it is now? I mean, it essentially,
I think still it's quite a ferocious debate depending
on how close people are to the research.
Perhaps some on one side of the coin being
almost anti
machine learning anti this sense
that it's just all hype and, and why we've been doing this
to the other side
that really do see it as being,
you know, the next
generation of, of methods from,
I know we'll maybe expand this to
a broader debate around scientific foundational models.
But on the turbulence modelling side,
how would you summarize how it is today?
Yeah. So, I mean, I've been saying this almost, I mean, first of all, I think
you're right, that has been
ferocious debate
right from the beginning.
And uh I don't know which side is louder
right now.
Um uh
But, but I think
uh if you want me to summarize the state of the field,
I want to like separate a few things here, right? One
early on especially and maybe even recently when somebody publishes a paper
saying, hey, here is a method,
right? So from the viewpoint of the person
who publishes it,
the viewpoint of the turbulence model, they're looking for a model,
they're not looking for a method, right?
So that is that disconnect, um which
I think can be bridged better by being very clear about what the objective is,
right?
Um Yeah, but beyond that,
I've been saying this
all the way from 2013 now,
uh maybe as a way to, you know, hedge,
I don't know what about why I started
presenting my work this way. So I would go through this
hour long talk on
data driven turbulence modeling.
And then at the end, I would say
I have not
presented to you a new approach to turbulence modelling.
I'm providing a new tool
that you can use, right?
And from that perspective,
you know, what have we do? What have we been,
what have we been doing as a community from 1960
right? We have some ideas, we put together
a model and then we leave some coefficients to be calibrated.
And
in the way we make up some functions
right along the way
and then
using some very few data points like the log layer and
jets and things like that we calibrate coefficients or constants.
Um
So at least my view has always been
do not abandon that by any means,
but use these new tools,
right, which can
potentially help you
uh in just
more information
and uh maybe do things in a, in a better way. But that doesn't mean
again, I do not want the focus to be on the machine learning. In fact,
I organized a very successful conference in Ann Arbor about 2017
and I was on a war path.
It was on data driven turbulence modeling.
I said we should never use machine learning
in the abstract or in the title
because that is one piece, right?
The modeling is the most important piece
and then
the data is another piece,
right? So the machine learning is a little tool in this process.
And
even without using it,
there are many ways to like massage the data, right,
to get you the information you need.
So,
so it is a tool and I do not think a machine learning first or an AI first approach,
at least in turbulence mind, we can talk about other fields where
purely data driven machine learning type of or AI approaches can
take you almost all the way.
But here it is a tool in the modeller's toolkit
and to use it judiciously
as you have been using it in the past,
right? Without
overfitting, et cetera.
I think that's the way forward.
It has always been the way forward. In my opinion.
Even though I would publish a paper, I did not claim to
say I have solved this problem. I said here is a method you can use
with your own
uh judicious interpretation of what needs to be done with this tool.
Yeah.
Yeah, I guess it's always um
like with anything, there's always an overreaction to things sometimes where
people. But I guess the turbulence modelling community in general
has,
has a large sort of quite conservative nature.
I would argue as well, which probably makes it even harder for
um
newer methods to perhaps come in to, to, you know,
to the phrase because people are used to doing a certain
way. Um
What, um
and I guess this would also
I'm not as familiar, but I would assume transition models as well are equally, I
mean,
maybe a slightly changing uh angle a little bit.
I think one of the areas you also work on is some of the hypersonics work. And I believe
transition modeling is one of the most complicated parts of that.
Have you seen equally that,
you know, for all these models of tons of coefficients and models that
machine learning can,
can play a part also in transition modeling that
it's not just about turbulence modelling per se.
Yeah, there's certainly quite a bit of work and
I've always said this um
that I think even though neither problem has been solved to an extent
that, you know, we would be happy with the methods.
I've always maintained that transition modeling may be
more amenable to this data driven disciplines
because
at least there,
there is a hope
that you can cover many possible regimes using
hyper
data and experiments
because the Reynolds numbers tend to be
smaller
by definition
right than the other way.
But of course, in some senses,
the
the quality of measurements
has to be better. But
I think one of especially when
you know, the
the field has become more model consistent, I can tell you more what that is
the ability to work with
um
integral data like ski
friction or heat transfer wall he flux can still drive these models. So,
so I think in a sense,
I mean, quite, I would say
about 20% of the work may be
moving towards transition these days. That was not the case earlier.
And one of our first um
applications in this field was bypass transition modeling
or at least methods for bypass transition modeling
to be more
size.
So yes, there is a lot happening in the field and
the fact that it is possible to run
uh DNS
at four or at least close to the condition that we want.
And that being a rich source of high quality data, I think is something that is
very useful.
So the turbulence modelling on one side.
So you could argue you're still, as you said, maintaining, um
you're still using a traditional solver,
whether it's commercial solver, open source government
and you're plugging in your tuning coefficient.
Um One of the points that you brought up and seems to be strong interest is
replacing
all of it
versus a surrogate model.
What's your
view on that is this, let's say if we take just for now, um
like I say an external aerodynamic example, like like an aircraft,
do you see that
a
turbulence modelling machine learning fix is the way
to ultimately get more accuracy and speed and,
and all the the merits that people discuss
or do you see that actually a surrogate model
is the sort of better route and better angle given the advances in machine learning?
Yeah, I,
I think it certainly depends on the application how
that computational result is going to be processed.
You know, if you're doing design exploration,
I do feel that a surrogate model for quantities of interest
can take you,
you know, can give you a lot of benefits, right?
But if you are
going to be probing some details of the flow physics,
um
and you want it to be somewhat general, I do not think a surrogate model
can get it
done.
Um unless you parameterize the problem
and there are a few parameters and you hit parameter space properly and then
you can crunch through some, some
large data.
Uh You can't quite do it. The reason tends to be following, right? Like
whenever we think of a surrogate model, we think of a system,
right? And you have a lot of data on that system and you want to be
um
developing
some representation of that system.
But
the take the classical CFD turbulence modeling approach where
you can
at least in theory
run a problem for which you have seen no data for,
right,
a different system from the
systems or subsystems where you trained your model, right? So that's the whole
discovery process where
let's say you want to design a hypersonic aircraft,
maybe I have data for the
an inlet. I have data from some shock bound
interaction.
I have some
eran
data.
The advantage of going through the classical CFD slash PDE route is you can
in principle extract information from these different sub components.
And if you do that properly, you can take that to this unseen problem,
right?
Whereas if you go with the surrogate, you do not have that flexibility,
you have to have data from that system
or a parameterized version of that system.
And if it is a discovery task, then
you cannot get off the ground,
right.
So that's why I think,
you know, as I said earlier at uh uh machine learning is a is a tool of the modelers,
toolkit.
All of these are
tools in the designer toolkit.
So they help you
address different parts of the design or discovery or analysis process.
So yeah, both have a room
and
in certain circumstances,
it makes a lot of sense
to
go with the surrogate model for quantities of interest.
And in many cases, it makes no sense to do that right?
And go with this other approach. So yes, both need both need to be like you would
as a source of information to address different parts of the spectrum.
But what about um
physics informed approaches, physic driven approaches like like PINNs that,
uh depending on the paper you read and the person you speak to have a,
a much bolder claim of, of ultimately being able to solve the PDEs and therefore
potentially move away
or combine those two together in the sense of being able to
um
not be relying just on the data that you've trained it on. Uh
what's your uh opinion on those methods?
Yeah. So I have worked on PINNs almost from
the early days of PINNs.
Obviously, I looked at
uh George
Karniadakis papers and other things and from probably the very first,
very first week it was put on archive or maybe even before that because
I think one of the students had given a thought,
I've been trying it, right. So
I think if your problem is simple,
right?
Um
And you do not have a code,
I, I think it's a good idea, right?
In the forward sense in terms of solving A P
uh but where it,
you know, runs into tough ground is we are pretty damn good at solving pds, you know,
over the past century, we have so many reliable methods.
Um
And
uh putting the PD in the loss function, there are a few uh few things that are not
um
uh appealing. Right? First,
you, it's in the loss function. So by definition, you're doing it,
you're not
solving it exactly, you're,
you know, reducing the residual to some level
and that may be OK as a surrogate model in some applications.
But even more so, right, if you think about all of the things we have learned
in our numerical analysis classes and in our compressible flows
is
the discreteness of the problem matters, right?
Your weak form matters. Um
You have Riemann solvers, you have
when you a continuous form is not the same as a discrete form.
So you kind of lose that uh at least in the classic formulation of the PINNs.
And there are some approaches that try to approach it from a different way like
Koumoutsakos at Harvard, he has a method called ODIL
that tries to keep the discrete form.
But even if you ignore whatever I said so far,
purely in terms of speed,
I
have a hard time believing that for complex PDEs, these methods can
beat
conventional ways of solving PDEs just because
I think the baseline is really good. So this is how,
you know, I, when I
maybe we'll get into this later, when I talk about
what are all the successful problems in AI for science?
And I list a few things and PDEs will almost never be there.
And that's
partly because
the baseline is very good,
right?
We are very good at solving PDEs.
All of that said
when you go the other way inverse problems,
then I find a good application for, for PINNs.
I still can't say it's the best in class. It cannot,
it may or may not be
uh
it probably would not be the best approach to do
inverse problems uh using classical methods,
but it may be competitive
and
you
it does not have to compete against 100 years of,
of accumulated wealth of knowledge. So
so again, to summarize it
in certain circumstances, as a surrogate,
it could help.
And there are also hybrid versions, right?
You can inject some physics, you can inject some data
and it has that flexibility without all of this machinery that we need. And
your entire code could be like 60 lines and by
options about 60,000 lines
and inverse
problem solutions. So it has a place there.
Yeah, II I uh
I must confess, I always find it.
It's a tricky one because there's so
like I guess in the early days of any
field,
there's so many counter claims and claims that
it is sometimes hard to have a truly independent
view on it.
I suppose you have to ultimately like you, you know, you have to get into the code,
you have to look at it to really understand it.
But um
there was one
comment
and maybe this is a bit of a segue into the AI for science
when I was speaking to one of the previous guests that
scale
has become
the the main thing that that actually what has solved many of
the large language problem issues is just the sheer amount of data
and to the point that that is the focus not on
the uh
you know accuracy of the individual or the beauty of the algorithm.
So with that in mind,
and this discussion of data versus physics driven
is the real problem for fluid dynamics.
And more generally, AI for science, just
the data. And if we solve that
actually,
we will come a long way and we're just trying to solve a problem with so little data
that that's really the issue.
Um
So obviously like having more data helps,
it can only help
if we use it the right way.
But
if you want to like solve hard science problems,
I don't think any amount of data would be enough
or the amount of data to be required is so large that
that is not the main problem because we just cannot reach them, right? Again, unless
your problem is so well defined like alpha fold, you know, going from
amino acid sequences to protein structure.
So there
the problem is so
well posted, I shouldn't say well post but conducive to this kind of approach,
right?
But
because you asked a more gentle question,
I do not think that data is the biggest bottleneck
because you will not have enough to like
do that.
Um But uh so inductive biases or or being able to bring in physics
in tuition
and I need to be very clear
the right
or the most appropriate level of physics, not
anything you think, not some anything variant of something just because it,
it feels appealing to us.
Uh
It's, you know, people talk about symmetries and variances, beautiful ideas,
nothing wrong with that.
But
is that the most important thing for you to get
the answer you desire
or is that one other way of constraining the model
to
do what you think it
should be doing with that information
or
should it be just doing something else to, to get it to where you want to go? So,
um
again, if the question is is well posed and you have a means of acquiring the data,
then I would say
data is the biggest thing,
right?
So again, going back to alpha for,
I think they only had 170,000 proteins or something like that, that's not a lot.
The common
space is immense,
right?
And they were able to really solve the problem and advance the field.
But if you take something like turbulence modeling
in general,
that is not the answer. But if you have a system or a
class of assists you care about
and you have your data driven modeling tools
and you have a
connection to some experimental or numerical simulation approaches
that can get you the data you want,
then
yeah, I would say data is the most important piece. So it depends on
your problem and and what you want to do.
So maybe this is a good then se way to
this discussion around foundational models because
I think this, at least with some of the people I speak to is the most contested or
argued point within science that just as
large language models seem to be able to do so much
without being explicitly taught the grammar of a language or explicitly done
something then logically and people even confuse the terms and say,
well, can we not build
a foundational model for science or foundational model for fluid dynamics?
Where do you, you, you put,
you put recently on I believe a very um successful
symposium looking at this question of foundational models for science.
So maybe you could introduce a little bit the the challenge
and some of the ways that you think we can
address it.
This is a favorite
of
mine
just earlier. This year, we started a new center on scientific foundation models.
Um So there are foundation models for science
and then there are foundation models for
particular domains within science.
So there's I I want to make the distinction and we can cover both.
But uh I think to answer your question. Um
so
by definition, right, this foundation models tend to
do
um
general things in a very broad domain.
Whereas the classical AI techniques in science,
they tend to do,
they want to have a narrow application
and they tend to do something specific,
right?
Um
So some people say broad and shallow and narrow and deep.
But, you know, I don't want to go go that route.
Um
But,
but I think the,
the
uh discussion around large language models has been incredibly fascinating.
Right. So, because JJ, that was
maybe for natural language, it is,
it has really been
surprising even to, I think open AI,
I do not think they expected it to expected 3.5 to be,
to make that much of a splash because they pretty much had
whatever we saw in, in November 2022 they had it
a year ago, they just put an api
play.
Um
But I think,
I think the buzz can be explained in many different ways. So one is uh
the ability to ability of these large language models to
bring together different
concepts
and compose them, right? That I think is what
um I think
quite people off track, there's a beautiful paper from Princeton from
Sanjiv
aa's group
where he defines
topics and skills, right? A topic could be suing or mending or whatever, right?
And a skill could be
uh metaphor could be a skill
and then he passes these topics uh and then he in his prompt,
he he asks
um
the prompt in such a way that many of these skills and topics have to be
covered
and composed and then you get answers. And what he found was the larger the model,
the more composition was happening, right? Between these topics
and he made a very clear argument that
the commentator
space of topics and skills is so large that it is impossible for this
to have seen all of this in the data, right? So
the ability of these models to
to compose
and combine these different topics to a degree,
if you go more than seven or eight compositions, it breaks down
and and the small model would break down at three.
So there is already something like intelligence there.
And
if you so so to me,
even if these large language models do not get much better,
I think they can still be extremely useful, right? And
um I have a lot of thoughts on it,
but I want you to like ask me something more specific so that we can we can hit,
hit what you want to hit, not what
I want. No,
no, no, no,
this is,
this is good. So maybe um
one question is
do the architectures and the methods that are used for current foundational models
for things like ChatGPT or Llama or et cetera.
Can they be used largely as is or with minor modifications
for applications and science
or do we need completely different architectures to deal
with a?
So at a high level,
is it just a matter of using the same
thing and just plugging it into different data sources
or do we need fundamentally different
approaches than the sort of transformer style
that has been used to date.
I think the answer is both. Right.
Let's, let's talk about the first thing, let's say you wanna
have a uh
a scientific version of GPT-4, right?
So, as you said,
uh plugging into different data sources is certainly a start.
And I think that would certainly be
uh something that
would probably
be very beneficial.
So, for instance, uh
you know,
I was working on a fairly complicated mathematical derivation a few months ago
and I would have pinged GPT for about 50 times no less than 50 times
during the process about,
you know,
some statistical expectations and some expressions
that I was struggling to derive
maybe 49 out of those 50 times, it was wrong,
but 50 out of those 50 times, it was useful because I was prompting it.
And it was always
telling me pushing me in directions
that as a reasonably
sophisticated expert,
I could use that information
and know that
it is doing this arithmetic or is math wrong,
but it's thinking in the right direction, right.
So,
so, so that's why I feel there is a, there is a place for this.
And if you look at what GPT-4 and some of these other models have been trained of,
you never know what GPT-4 is trained on really.
But, you know, something like Google's P,
they've released
at least some statistics on what they trained on.
Science tends to be like
less than 5% or maybe
3% of the entire data corpus
sports was probably bigger than science
entertainment was probably 20 times bigger.
I don't know.
But
so just changing that balance
is gonna be enormously useful. And
our colleagues at Oregon National lab
have actually started that process of
curated scientific data, you know, from journal papers
and guiding the process. So I think that
even if the base is just in large language model with some multimodal capabilities,
I think that is still going to be very useful uh in many different tasks.
Um And there's also this this
confusion
or maybe misguided emphasis on
these things being able to like solve your problems.
But I think the best use of these models
in my opinion, at least for the next
15 years,
nobody can predict the future. But at least the next decade
is to use these as assistance,
right?
For things that you want to be doing
and for this to be doing the
the low end of the
uh
scientific process, right? You were still,
you know, looking at the
details and
you're using, you're guiding it.
But
yeah, to answer your question more directly, I feel
even a GPT-4 like
base
um
but
architecture but with uh the right data can take us a long way.
But I also want to talk a little bit about,
you know, even within this architecture,
there is a lot we can do to improve
the output, right? For instance,
these things are trained to complete the next
token, right? In,
in,
in at least supervised unsupervised pre training,
they just complete the next word.
And it's not really
as some people say, thinking before speaking.
But if even that part can be iterative,
I think you can still get a huge performance gain.
OK.
And
um
being able to provide additional context
or being able to
connected to agents that can go look for other things,
even this architecture,
even if
the architecture doesn't get better. And even if
um
the language part of the model doesn't get better
if it's done, right?
I think it can be massively beneficial
for science.
So are you referring a little bit more to the idea of
during the conceptual phase?
So not simulations now, but just more scientific discovery like
developing a hypothesis or analyzing flow fields? Or
you're saying that you could be using these
transformer style models to help in that side,
not just the replace
physics based simulations
by machine learning. That's kind of what you
Yeah. Yeah. So I only answered the first part of your previous question, right.
I said
if we just stick with
LLMs and transformers,
even if you do that,
right? With some tinkering with the
with the way it's trained, like I said,
not just complete the next word but maybe one day
today
and that's not too hard to do.
So I think that will
automatically help but then,
and it can help data processing, it can help you,
you know, code up, it can help you in so many ways as scientific assistant.
But for other more regular science tasks that we do,
of course transformer architectures on their own won't cut it. We need
newer architectures and
I wouldn't even say newer.
Uh
most of these things have existed in, in some form for a while.
We just, as you said earlier
scale, we are scaling it up and we are
uh
I would say
you can hobble it as
Ian
Foster
from
or God
says it.
But yes,
uh different architectures but not necessarily completely
radical that doesn't exist so far.
So with that, like maybe diving into
perhaps some examples and because I've always been
having this sort of theoretical debate
with um with some colleagues.
So if you wanted,
what do you see as the definition of foundation or do?
Is it really realistic if we just look at CFD
that instead of using a code by company X, you know that you put settings in
that it could be economically viable,
that there could be a model
trained on enough
incompressible compressible, low speed, high speed, you know,
all different flow regimes
that you could essentially then give it a geometry and it has seen somewhere
enough to be able to give you an answer
or
do you see
that it is more likely a quote unquote foundational model that is
for a particular flow regime or a particular use case.
Um answer could be both. But
if you'd ask me maybe
six months ago, I would have said the first thing is fiction,
but my thinking has evolved on this
and there's also been some work trying to train these models on different
kinds of domains and
introducing body conditions by masking and things like that.
Um So I think it is possible, right? So think about
it is, but, but your question was to get an answer,
even get an answer.
I don't think that answer would be terrible,
but it probably won't
satisfy all of your needs, right? So think about,
think about uh
uh
an immerse boundary type approach
where you can put in any geometry, you can put in boundary conditions with the meshes
condition and then
your geometry gets
represented,
you know, as a cut cell or mask or whatever it is,
I really think and there's a paper from Anima
Anan
Kumar's group,
a
Kumar's group that does something very similar.
So I do think
even, and it's not like very complicated,
I think even within the next couple of years, we may see
something like that.
Uh
that is somewhat reliable,
that can give you
an answer. That
could be,
I'm just making up a number here
like 75 80% accurate.
In my opinion, that is still useful
because
that's not your final thing. That could be your
precondition or that's the first guess
that you want to explore in many different ways.
I really feel
that
that kind of capability is not fiction.
I would not have been as confident in my answer six months ago.
Um So right now we're running a summer school and we are,
one of the hackathon groups is actually trying something
like that and I'm actually seeing that in action.
So yes, it is possible to,
to get there. But
you know, if you go to a purist and say,
hey, look at this answer, they only look at
where it's wrong.
And I think that that view is
OK from
uh uh uh
guardrail perspective.
Um
But then the other question you asked, you know, for a class of problems,
I think
yeah, many tools that
even pre foundation models, many tools we've been developing
can actually get us there. And in fact, I even covered one such example earlier
and I spoke about
if you're able to parameterize the problem,
then
I think
AI can, these MS techniques purely data driven
can do
you know a lot of damage already.
And then with these foundation models thrown in especially foundation models
that can interact with agents,
right? At least that's my notion of how these things would be useful in the future.
Even if
these GPT-4 like models or GP T five or whatever they are, even if
they plateau in their accuracy,
their ability to interface with more specialized agents
to carry out tasks in more specific tasks
and then being able to synthesize information back.
I think to me that's the most realistic or pragmatic
scenario of how these tools will evolve in the next decade or so.
But um
some would say that this opens up a very interesting uh
commercial or ethical angle or both.
So one is
if,
if, if you were to make a foundational model,
let's say that is
for conceptual design, so not super high accuracy, but for conceptual design,
um
most of that data is public,
you know, like a hypersonic vehicle, not many uh hypersonic vehicles,
all the results are in the public domain
or for a um
or even for like road cars, you know, a lot of those are kept commercially sensitive.
How do you think
we would get around the the data availability
issue?
Yeah, that's an interesting question for which I don't think one person can answer
but, but remember there are two stages that is this pre training stage
and then there is the fine tuning stage. So when I say this will be useful,
the pre training may not be as sophisticated,
but every organization can have its own
fine tuned
fine tunable data sets
and that
can be private,
that can be as sophisticated as they want,
right?
And then there may be enough, you know,
there is enough open source activity out there even for
something like hypersonics, even though
I think at least in the near future things will be more closed than open.
There is enough open source research
happening
um
in this country and in Europe and other countries that
I think getting the
data sets for pre training
is not unrealistic,
but then the magic would be but that on its own,
I do not think is going to be
helpful for problems
that are not closely related to,
you know, the big uh
the over
represented parts of the data set. But
so the fine tunable parts, I think that will be the most valuable. And as you know,
the pre training is a bulk of the cost, right?
It's about 95 99% of the cost is in pre training, generally speaking,
and
then people can have their own fine tune things
within their organizations.
So how um
how can
how can the community go about and do this then? So what are the practical
challenges you put on the symposium to look at foundational models?
But what needs to be
done
essentially to enable this?
Yeah, I think, you know, anytime a new field,
newish field emerges,
you need to get people together and talk, right?
So that's really the first step that we have
organized here
and we had this conference in April of this year. So next
uh
summer or early summer, we're planning the next version of this meeting and
it's gonna be a really big deal with
all the names you hear in the news,
hopefully most of the names at least uh to be to be present.
So I think so that's
one activity right to,
to be able to discuss ideas, to be able to discuss tools, to have tutorials, you know,
to propagate this thing.
Um But beyond that,
there are already a few things that are happening uh in creating these
subdomain
groups.
And
at least if some of visions, visions come true,
we may have a multi
university
uh government industry
consortium. I call it as, as futures IFM Institute
where we go through this process. But I would like you to look at, you
know, there is one organization, I don't know if you know,
it's called the trillion parameter consortium.
It's kind of laid out of organ
and uh
they already have probably like
50 universities. Michigan is a part of it and a few national labs and not just the US
it, it's easy website to remember T PC dot DEV
T pc.de.
And they're already facilitating precisely the
kind of things you're talking about,
right?
They're organizing,
they talk, they talk to AC M and they've organized
access to the journals.
They are basically setting a benchmark, they're setting up evaluations
that is still to support the science,
the Open Science Foundation model in particular.
But that is the community that is the farthest along
in
uh
enabling the kind of thing
you're talking. But that
is not a body that,
you know, gives you money to do research, right?
But, but we are, you know, envisioning this
this kind of institute with
uh
you know, government funding and philanthropy and venture funds
to make sure there are also the resources needed.
But uh you know, starting with some of our activities as part of the next
foundation models conference in in May 2025
we already have some of those structures built up
as you know, uh we
collaborate with larger organizations. So
um
if you take CFD, which is our traditional domain,
there are those
eco
tact data sets and there are
maybe about 10 or 12 such sizable clusters.
I mean that would be a start. But then if you have an open way to
uh bring data in
and hopefully some resources to train it and then more importantly, incentives.
So I think the incentives have to change right now. At
least so far,
the academic and the scientific community
incentivizes
certain class of
activities as more valuable or more procedures
and that has to change, right?
Uh
And I think
to me the one of the most exciting
um
aspects of
aspect of foundation models
is the idea that for the first time
in human history, I must say
there is a possibility of
say thousands of domain scientists collaborating
on the same platform, right?
You know, some of them are contributing data,
some of them may be fine tuning some of them are building the architecture,
some of them are doing evaluations.
Um you know, some of them are probing the models,
some are developing architectures, but it is the same platform.
That's
kind of
pretty crazy if you think about
how it changes the nature of collaborations, which tend to be kind of loose,
you know, unless you have a project like
and other things.
Um but still
this can be more direct, everyone's working
on the same platform on the same type of model
and bringing their pieces in.
And
I, I think many
countries I think will start to coalesce around us
because of the fact that this is a collaboration tool that is
that is unprecedented.
But again, I think the
the benefit would be
uh when this model kind of interacts with those agents, right?
And some people may be developing those specialized agents
like for protein folding or turbulence modeling or whatever.
So, so I think you can unify domains within science and science itself.
And this is the first
platform that allows people to do that,
right?
So I like that idea.
Uh I, I think what your vision is is more of a
and I haven't heard this articulated in such a clear way,
you're saying essentially that
we sometimes double down and focus in this fluid domain CFD domain on PINNs or on,
you know, neural operators on things.
But you, you're already seeing them as the sort of the the agents
that a future sort of large language model can be calling,
but there needs to be also the investment on the underlying or the,
the main thing that's calling those agents and,
and able to interpret what we're asking.
And that's something that perhaps hasn't been as widely spoken about.
At least I've not heard this as much and
I'm appreciating you saying this because it's kind of making sense in my head now.
Um,
and I guess it can learn
vice, you know,
the agents can learn from what the large,
large language model is doing and vice versa, I guess to,
you know, to do that.
Um
I do want to mention one important thing, right? So it is
the the large model, the agents
and the humans also in the loop doing this general guidance and evaluating
but
taken together.
I think this has the potential to
be a new way of
or
to be more conservative here, a new tool to do science,
but
a collaborative tool that has not existed, right?
Well, you, you probably know where I'm going to go next with this because
I'm always never sure.
And I think it's a global debate on regulation and, and the ethics.
I know that when I've spoken to various,
you know,
um colleagues or people at conferences or, or wherever
there then starts to be this, you know, light bulb moment where you realize, hold on,
you're condensing a lot of knowledge into a,
into one thing
and most software packages are
have I A restrictions or have some form that stops them going, you know,
to other places.
Is it the case,
how difficult is it going to be to do this fully open source?
Yeah. Well,
again, what is open source is, is
the the first question, right? Like
whatever is available,
open source right now
has data
under the use it under the right terms,
I think could be fair game
for
the pre training, the pre trained part of the foundation model.
And then there's a fine tuning and the agents that become a little more specific,
right?
So again, I'm not an expert on this topic, but even
in that scenario,
there are many things to worry about
what is,
you know, you spoke about. Uh
I don't know which two words you spoke about, but you didn't talk about,
you didn't mention security, right?
What if
you know, something comes out of this, that
could be potentially
a risk to
national security or, you know, some other thing that we worry about.
So that's certainly an open question. And I'm not,
I mean,
I was comfortable talking about everything before
this because I thought about this.
I kind of worked on some aspects,
but that's not my expertise. So,
but I would say yes, I mean, we have to look at this very carefully.
Um
But I think what is openly available
can be used,
right, for that. And then
for things that are more
uh
this open science foundation model
um
is not the only open, only science foundation model that would be out there,
right?
Um But the the thing there, of course, the risk there is
people organizations,
countries that have more access to more resources and
more compute and more data will have their own,
more powerful foundation models.
Um And these are going to be very expensive to train
if you ask me, are they useful? I would say, absolutely.
Are they always going to be accurate? Absolutely not,
but they can still be huge productivity,
they can still,
you know,
result in huge productivity gains.
And I think from a
uh
national interest,
I think
countries should be investing in this because
of the potential.
But is it worth investing
$7 trillion?
Like Sam Altman
says,
that's a different debate to be had.
Um
But, but,
but I think,
you know, I wish in the next year or two or at least as soon as possible.
At least
the only thing I feel strongly about this is there is
this whole thing about artificial general intelligence and you know,
we want, we will get there by
in five years
to 10 years. I think that's a big distraction
given what these tools can already do
and what these tools can,
can do in the next few years without that goal, if that is the goal,
I think people be disappointed, very disappointed.
In my opinion.
But if you have more pragmatic goals about
productivity boost scientific assistance
and
you're able to
work with the
realization that these things will never be perfect.
They may not be able to tell you something
drastically new,
but they can still be a massive productivity boost.
I think even within the next few years, we'll see great benefits come out of it.
Well, I guess
the previous episode gave an opinion and I
was interested to see what you think of this
around the role of academia, the tech sector and start ups
to achieve this vision you're talking about of, you know, a new platform,
new technology for scientific discovery.
What where do you see the roles of all three of them?
Where does academia fit into this? Where are start ups required? Where are the
tech companies needed
or industry?
This is I'm glad you asked me this because
one of the
exciting aspects of the
platform that I described earlier
was because
different
uh
kinds of organizations can do different things, right?
I do not think at least in the next two or three years,
academia would be doing the pre training
because I mean, you need
10,000 GPUs just to get off the ground, right? So
that's not what academia is
probably ever going to be good at. But then
almost everything else that I mentioned,
right,
data curation, I mean,
traditionally
academia has been keepers of knowledge, right? And this is,
this is just baked in,
right?
Maybe they don't have access to all kinds of data, but the open data, right. So that's
that is where academia is at its strongest.
And then let's go down downstream, right? Let's talk about
being specialized agents. What does academia do?
Basic research, specialized, narrow.
So that is the clean role there
and
maybe even the fine tuning process. And then,
you know, if you talk to
people who are
developing these science foundation models and
probably any kind of foundation model
right now, they're not complaining about when I talk to them,
they're not complaining about data, they're not complaining about compute.
They're saying the most important thing is evaluation
and feedback.
You know, I can again envision a
future where
um
as part of
many
classes that masters or PhD students or undergraduate students take
where
they may be evaluating or fine tuning or creating data,
right?
Uh
So,
and this kind of expertise and and
human scale only exists
for for these kind of tasks only exist in academia.
And of course, there's a lot of basic research needed to improve architectures
to uh
as again, as as people say,
coming of it,
much better ways of
much better, much better ways than just complete the next word
uh this iterative process. So this is where academia has, it has its strongest.
So except that one pre training block,
I think academia is in a nice position to contribute
e everybody else
and then you have
national laboratories
uh
who are very well placed
uh for certain parts of,
you know, this, this this ecosystem.
Um
how do
companies come in
that
complicates things a little bit because
mostly
these are for profit
and so they have their own goals and some of those goals, thankfully,
I think overlap with some of these broader ambitions we have
and certain companies,
it is in their best interest to sell more GPUs.
So I'm sure I'm
sure they can help in, in, in, in addressing part of the research and the
and the computing resource kind of spectrum.
Uh So,
so I think
all these organizations
can have a very clear
role in
this entire process, entire platform.
And that is again,
very exciting to me, right? Even even companies that are,
that have
different goals than academia
and national labs,
which have slightly different goals than academia and companies,
I
think there is still so much common ground
that maps to like one
part of the platform or the other.
I don't know if you have this similar thought, but I do often wonder, I mean,
I don't envy
the people at the top of Seamen's or Dasso
or Ansys or cadence
who are probably faced with a a complication.
Do I
bet the House essentially on, you know,
really going in on AI and machine learning and this idea of
scientific foundation models because
you know, a
lot of scientific discovery is done using
their billions of dollars worth of software packages, you know,
throughout engineering and science
or
do we
continue
and make even better these higher fidelity, you know, physics based simulators?
Do you know to me that like
there was not,
well, I guess there is in large language models, there were companies
already doing things and I guess Adobe and Microsoft and others are, are in there.
But just give my point,
what role do you see for these massive companies already in the
simulation space who arguably have the most to gain or lose from
um these new methods?
Um
I'm glad you just asked, you just restricted your
domain to
simulation.
So that's easier to answer.
If they bet the House on foundation models, I think it would be foolish.
I think if they bet the house purely on AI, that would also be
foolish.
But if they ignore this,
that's even more foolish.
So, so that is, I think a happy medium where
whatever you've been doing and whatever you are very good at
those can be agents. Remember, agents don't just have to be AI agents, right?
An agent could be your
uh beautiful
solver,
right?
And it may
maybe there is an AI angle to it,
but it doesn't matter. But I think,
you know, I mentioned earlier about
uh
probing an evaluation
if there is something that's fairly trustworthy
like your solver that you've developed for 20 years,
that can play an enormously useful role in this
evaluation process.
You know, the
foundation model can generate a prior that can be evaluated or fine tuned,
right and brought back in. So
whatever you have been good, I don't think AI fundamentally changes
many things that we have been doing. In fact, I think it can
help
drive more value
also because AI on its own has many shortcomings that cannot be addressed
using
data
alone. So,
so yes,
I mean for those simulation companies,
um you know, being
uh
cognizant of some of the developments
and then
even taking open source models and
maybe you don't want to spend enormous amount
of computer on on this pre training stage.
But
uh collaborating with institutions like I mentioned
earlier, right, if we have
an Open science foundation model,
then
maybe
Stevens
can provide you shouldn't name particular names, but
the particular companies can provide
services
in the context of the tools that they already provide,
right?
So I think there are a lot of opportunities there at the intersection
of what you're already good at with all of these things happening.
And of course, some other companies that
I think certain certain simulation companies that
are already part of a bigger conglomerate.
I am absolutely sure every company has this in their vision
and they may have their own
context specific uh
models that
will be interface. So
the short answer to the question is. Yeah. Don't bet the house fully on this. But,
uh,
it's not something that can be ignored either,
but at the same time I'm sure there is completely
unreal, unrealistic expectations all over the place from
customers and
management.
Yeah.
It's kind of interesting if I speak to some of my friends who work in industry and
it's hard to know because sometimes you don't know whether you're in the bubble,
you know, by being in a certain thing. But
they are almost to the point where they're sick of people pitching stuff to them.
And, you know, it's almost,
you know, the classic response is, well, you know,
we've had reduced order models for decades, you know, you're just rebranding this.
So there
is, I think the danger of some of the hype of AI in general
and if you go in too early into a field, promising the world,
it can sometimes burn trust or it's a do,
do you see that sometimes in your discussions?
Yeah, for sure. And, and, and I don't know if, you know, I
have a start up as well and
it's called
Gin s dot A. I, we've been going for about
five years
and even before the foundation models, we, we had the same kind of challenges,
right?
People think
it's like
very little data, you can create magic.
Uh But I think
what has worked for us right from the beginning is by
setting these expectations
and saying hey,
this can,
I mean, just be very clear about what it can do well and what it could do
and what it cannot do
and being very clear
and you know, being honest about it, I think, I think there is a, there is a way here,
but you're right. I mean, there is
we have faced some customer scenarios where
understanding of
the capabilities of this technology is so unrealistic.
Um
but it's an iterative process
ultimately.
If you're able to show
that
there is something that can be done at lower cost or, you know, in,
in quicker time with reasonable accuracy,
then that iterative process, you know,
I think will take hold ultimately, right? Nobody's going to argue against
actual utility, right? It's the perceived utility
and hype that
uh cloud things up.
Yeah. Yeah.
Um One of the things
I've tried it in all the episodes where possible is
a bit of, well, career advice, I guess. And
you've
rose to be a very prominent and successful professor at leading university.
You have your own start up. Your
many people look at people like you and they often wonder, well,
how did you get there?
How can I get
there?
Um
This is a difficult question to ask because I
know it's very dependent on people's roots and everything.
But what have you learned along the way? If people are wanting to go
um into academia, they're wanting to rise, they think. Oh,
would you do the same as you did and the
paths that you would take differently as advice you would
give
if you, OK, let me frame it. You're a PhD student. Now,
you're already doing a PhD, let's say, in fluid dynamics.
And you would like to become a full professor one day.
What, what would be your advice to that
PhD student?
So that's
a
question to answer then, the more broader question, although
I have been asked that question
quite a few times, right? So,
so I think
I did the first part very briefly and then get to the second part, right? For me,
the only thing that has
driven me is curiosity
and, you know, not defining a
control volume, saying this is what I'm interested in
but being intensely curious and then slowly growing the control volume
to come
for certain things. And
none of,
I mean, if you say I'm successful, then in your view, I'm successful.
But I don't define
things that way. But what has worked for me is
just pursuing the curiosity
but also not forgetting what needs to get done
on the site, right? To keep the trains running on time.
Uh But yes, what advice would I give my PhD students? Uh
Maybe I'll, I'll interject another question. I get asked a lot, right?
When people ask about,
I get asked this, I mean,
I've given about 20 talks over the past few months just on these AI topics and
this question comes up,
you know, I want to specialize in AI for science
or my group ones. Uh So where should we start? And what should we be focusing on?
My first answer always is
get really good at the science
because the AI is not going to solve any scientific problem
to a greater degree than what the expert solves. But
if you have a very good understanding of,
of the domain
and you do not lose any rigor there and then you pick up the essentials of AI,
then it can help you
be much more productive
and uh
you know, hopefully like leverage it in the right way. So,
so I think I would give the same kind of advice.
Um
You know,
the foundations are the most important pieces
you're, you know, losing,
I mean, without losing rigor in, in, in, in, in mathematics, physics,
chemistry and biology, where, where, where it matters.
Um
then every
AI and all of these techniques that come about, right,
are
basically layers that are built by combining these different different nodes.
And
um I think for those who have that perspective
and have a solid foundation, I think moving into new areas is, is, is, is,
is much easier.
But
I think your question certainly has
one important aspect that I want to highlight, right? So
if you think about
how academia has changed
or even nature of research has changed in the past two decades.
Um
when I was a graduate student,
everybody pretty much in my line of work would write a solver from scratch,
right. So that has changed completely,
you know, one PhD would be running an le
properly.
That was, I
think at the
Stanford
would say that even like
10 years ago.
So all of that is changing.
So,
and to be a faculty member, to be a, a professor at the university like Michigan,
you were the expert in your domain
and you had a big impact in the field that has changed
AI or not, right? Because
globally, there is just
lot of researchers, you know, looking at these topics. So
if your foundations are very strong and this is not just for academia,
this is for industry and national labs as well.
If your foundations are very strong and then you're curious then
uh without losing that
core aspects,
being able to navigate into newer and newer areas and adapt and be flexible,
I think that becomes
easier.
And my PhD students,
you know, II I
I called the PhD program at least in my lab as a,
as a training exercise to equip you with the skills
rather than
just to like solve a problem from end to end. So gain as many skills as possible.
But the most important thing is, is, is the rigor that
um
makes you see things and connections
and makes you navigate those
as
seamlessly as possible, very rarely meet
academics at the top of that profession who aren't
genuinely excited and interested and, and feel almost like,
you know, they're running their own start up.
I know you also have a start up but, you know, you, you kind of,
compared to an industry,
I speak to far more people who are a little bit miserable and sort of depressed
and I know academic academia has many problems
but normally when I speak to an academic,
they are still genuinely
reasonably positive um about at
least the flexibility they have and the ability to set
sort of their directions.
Yeah, it is like I never left grad school or sometimes I've never
left
kindergarten, right. I get to play with these amazing
tos and tools and get to collaborate with people. It's
just an amazing place to be, but
it's not without its challenges, right? Especially the first
seven or eight years in academia can be extremely stressful for some people,
not everybody.
And of course,
the move from postdoc
to
assistant professor
is also very competitive.
Um
and it's maybe not for everybody. But I think for like you said, if you are
genuinely driven by curiosity and passion and you are um
you know, you, you're,
you're paying your bills
for things that you have to pay your bills. I think it's incredibly rewarding
career.
So maybe as
a final question, as a bit of an outlook to the, to the future
and I know these are always hard. So maybe more
thematically where, where you see it
if you were to fast forward now and you're doing your symposium in five years time,
what do you think will have been the big achievements by them?
What do you think will be, will there still be the gen AI hype?
And it will keep going will have there been in the winter of AI and
people will be moving on to new things like quantum or where do, where do you see
in five years time though
the academic world around,
let's say, let's restrict it to fluid dynamics just,
just to make it a little bit easier to
predict.
Yeah, first of all, I mean, even next year, it won't be my symposium.
It could be the community symposium.
I
think a whole bunch of
us together, we come together to organize it.
Yeah, but, but uh
you know, II I,
especially in AI, right, predictions never
go to plan.
You know, I think in 1971 of the most famous AI DS such as ever,
Marvin Minsky of MIT who started their AI lab,
he said in, in 3 to 8 years,
you'll have a machine with general intelligence of an average human being.
And
I think in 1965 they said within
six years,
we will have
a computer that will be the best human chess player.
Um
So in that sense,
uh
I would say, I mean, I think these things will happen at some point.
But
what I, what I have learned
from listening to many party leaders,
including Jeff Hinton and all of these people.
Yeah, thought leaders tend to compress,
compress time frames a lot, right? So I will not
give you
uh precise answers on what will happen in five years.
But uh
I feel
uh
there may be one big leap
in
the capabilities of
modules like GPT-4.
Um
But I don't know if it would be as big as going from zero to GPT-3.5.
But,
but there'll be one big leap there.
Um But in, in, in more restricted domains like D
modelling, I think
again, maybe this is more of a hope.
There is no two camps, there is only one camp
and because it's a turbulence modeling, there should only be turbulence modelers
who use these tools better. There is no like AI people and
traditional modelers.
So I think it's already been
slowly like coming together because
I mean, I'll be honest, right?
In 2012, I could write anything and I could, it could be published
um in this topic because it was just new.
And then slowly uh people had to show
that
I'm not just doing a periodic
learning, I'm being more consistent
and then almost every paper that people are working on now,
it has to show some level of generalization
which I was not doing
in 2013,
I was training and testing on same or very similar things.
So in that sense, the field is moving
but I still have not.
And
because of the nature of how funding works,
you know, if you get like
$500,000 from NSF,
you're addressing a very specific question and you will publish papers
to address that very specific question.
You know, we need a broader thing like in the US, we have things called new
multi universities admissions.
So it's like
order of 77 $8 million.
So there now you're getting different kinds of
people together and not just developing methods,
you want to develop some solutions and that still has not happened
again, maybe that's an excuse, you know, my group has had it
enough different projects that maybe we could have done something like that, but
to have more unified uh
projects and collaborations where
the goal is to actually create better models rather than
showing what
your particular contribution
is doing.
So, so I think that
I think that will happen because
even in terms of publishing and even in terms of funding so far,
you being able to show a few things
has been good enough because the field didn't quite exist or mature.
But as with any field, once some of the lower
hanging fruit have been picked,
then
the demand, the market would, would desire actual progress.
And
I'm pretty sure in five years,
at least the mark. It's very clear what the market desires
and I think it will drive it towards the models. I don't, I still don't think
data driven or not. Uh
uh
general generalisable turbulence modeling
model exists because of
many things I go through going in that paper that you have to
tell you.
But I think for particular domains and flow regimes,
he just needs,
I, I think the methods are there,
the community, the community is big enough
uh
People just need to come together under the same umbrella
and then
some, some people have to come together and
I think you'll already see a lot of benefit.
Yeah.
Well, I won't test you in five years time
on that, but I'm pretty sure you're,
you're right that it seems to be one of those ones where um
there's enough swell
of people working on it that it seems
irreversible now in terms of momentum. Um
it doesn't seem
like quantum
where there was this
bit of a buzz.
But then it
uh I know that's a whole other topic how machine learning is sort of, you know,
push quantum aside a little bit from a lot of people's minds, but it feels like with,
with machine learning.
AI, there's
almost every person you speak to in the community is doing in some form.
Um So it, it feels like it can't really turn back. But
yeah, whether there'll be a
um
I guess in the weather domain, things like FourCastNet and GraphCast
have had their big moments.
Uh I guess what you're referring to is maybe uh
there needs to, if, if there is one in the
CFD, for example,
domain that would be enough of a catalyst to then convince industry as well
where it seems maybe there hasn't been that GraphCast,
FourCastNet sort of moment yet.
I would argue in CFDI,
I would say that it's not that the moment hasn't existed.
The question has not come up.
The
the weather, weather prediction is uh
is a sweet spot, right? For these techniques,
lots of data, lots of good quality data.
And then the question you're asking is you take one system
and you're saying,
predict
few days or
two weeks,
that's the only question you're asking.
And I think for that question,
I would say
the tools are fairly good, I say fairly good because
in my opinion,
these models don't need to be as sophisticated
and as expensive and they can still do a
nice job, right? But you're right.
So that's to me, that's more like
the sweet spot problem existed.
And the question was narrow enough
that you could. And those are the problems that I think AI
has been
really doing well, right?
Like
alpha fold is the prime example, very specific, very narrow question.
Now, if you say, can we go from
two weeks to
climate,
then
all of the work that's been doing then
needs a lot more, a lot more work.
So, to me, the,
the turbulence problem is more like the climate problem rather than the weather.
Yeah. Which is why I guess I was originally asking like, the,
maybe we, we need to set our standards a bit lower or our site a bit sort of narrower on,
like,
you know, even if you could develop something that proved you could design
a commercial aircraft,
that
is the thing where I
guess the picture has often been by, by some like all of CFD, which just seems almost
like
that's like predicting the weather on any planet in anywhere in the universe,
you
know,
by definition.
But yes, I think every organization within their, their confines,
I
think even full aircraft design is a bit too big for now.
But
yeah, it can change.
But even if your, if your thing is not,
you know, the weather prediction problem,
it's end to end AI. Right.
So that's like
really clean, I don't think end to end AI for something like aircraft design,
I don't think that will ever happen.
But
in the end to end spectrum,
I think already like
a
few gaps can be like closed
and because there are
uh human experts in the loop,
this can be beneficial.
But, but
otherwise,
yeah,
these tools are not useful without that human
expert being in the loop and guiding them.
But I think
as time progresses,
I think more of these gaps can be addressed and more productivity benefits can be,
can be achieved with not
much more sophisticated tools. It's just
having the
expertise to like integrate them and
guide them and do
the
well, I feel we could probably talk for hours on this,
which is the danger of AI and sort of science, it sort of becomes one of these,
you know, drinks over a beer in a pub.
Yeah, thank you so much.
And I really appreciate it and I definitely
would recommend people to follow you very closely.
I
genuinely everything you've done,
you seem to have a very good way of whether you know it
or not sort of predicting the future or predicting the path of science.
So, uh,
because I didn't know anything about the foundational thing and as
soon as I thought I saw you put it out,
I was like,
so he's done it again. He's, he's definitely sees where, where it needs to go.
So that, yeah,
having some curiosity and then having
the right people around me.
Ok. Yeah, very modest. But
a
group
of people.
Well, thank you again.
And, uh, yeah,
hopefully we get a chance to see each other at some conference uh in the future.
But yeah, for now, thank you very much.
See you around Neil. Thank you very much for this,
that